[Music]
like a very briefly tell you a little
bit about secretary bubbles academic
background he holds a degree Bachelor of
Arts in geology from north Dom and he
also holds a master's degree from
newcastle upon tyne in england which is
quite fascinating since I'm also a
holder of the same thing I mean not
quite the same degree I have a degree in
naval architecture from the same
University and we must have crossed each
other's paths in Newcastle since we were
even in the same building so we even
suffer together
spotted dick and whatever else the
British cuisine has to offer after that
he went to the other university I forget
it
I think it's upstream I think it's
Harvard yeah I'm sorry where he has
received the LLB from the Harvard Law
School secretary bhavat is in charge of
a department that is responsible for
safeguarding our environment a very very
important job for all of us he has a
unique style of management he promotes
consensus-based environmental
restoration projects which you know he
gets a buy-in from a large number of
constituents and then he as a result of
this unique style of management he has
been highly successful in a number of
areas this include Florida project
Pacific Northwest in California and a
number of others which I don't think I
really need to spend a lot of time today
so I'll give secretary Babbitt plenty of
time to speak but today what I like he
has graciously agreed to speak to us on
the subject of our conference and Emily
Maher
by invasions and to share with us his
plans for his department for ushering us
into the next millennium for a safe and
sound environment for all of us to live
in so secretary
[Applause]
Chris thank you very much you know I'm
really frankly surprised that you don't
remember me from our student days at
King's College at the University of
Newcastle actually there's an
interesting story there because as Chris
suggested I I did study science as an
undergraduate and I received a Marshall
scholarship - which took me to Great
Britain and at the University of
Newcastle and I had the great good
fortune to arrive there at the very
beginning of the plate tectonic
revolution in a really extraordinary
research group that was elaborating the
geomagnetic aspect of all of this
revolution was taking place and well it
was really quite exciting but after a
year and a half with my classmate here
and other truly talented physicists and
chemists and engineers I was walking
home one night after an especially
frustrating 12 hours in the lab
everything well you all know what that's
about
you know nothing seems to work and
nothing comes together and on my way
home I was reflecting I said you know I
think I've discovered what the problem
is I'm not smart enough to be a
scientist
and I continued to reflect and I ask
myself do I still have time to get into
a softer line of work
well there's still an opportunity I
thought I've got to downscale my
ambitions and that took me to Harvard
Law School from whence I degenerated
into law and then politics what am I
doing here today yeah that's a good
question my scheduling staff saw this
invitation from crisp which said a bio
invasive exotic marine invaders and so
we can go right past that one nobody is
interested besides it's a topic for NOAA
and it's in Boston
I mean why why could you possibly be
interesting I snapped it up they caused
I believe you are onto something of
extraordinary importance here and the
effort that the sponsors of this
conference have made and that you have
demonstrated by coming together mark
this event as a important beginning and
I think that many of you and your
respective fields are going to look back
upon this as saying you were present at
the creation that the creation of a
genuine response to what is now being
recognized as a large and pervasive
phenomenon that is that of necessity
must bring scientists policymakers and
the public together you know it's
interesting that we come here on the
10th anniversary of the Exxon Valdez and
you of course remember the attention
that that captured when this stone sober
captain crashed his
tanker on a reef in Prince William Sound
whereupon some ten or eleven million
gallons of oil spilled gradually slicked
across the shoreline and the sound and
alerted the awaken the American people
to the problem of oil spills as I saw
birds wildlife coated with all this gunk
struggling for survival and in fact that
incident galvanized some very important
response Congress legislated a double
halt tanker standard there was a massive
commitment to research to remediation
mitigation and a really worldwide
attention to dealing with the regulatory
aspects of
oil tankers the one thing that didn't
come out of that was attention to
something else that was happening in
Prince William Sound a couple of years
ago the Fish and Wildlife Service showed
up and said we've discovered four new
species of zooplankton loose and
spreading in Prince William Sound and of
course was very tempting to say that
sober captain of Exxon Valdez is
responsible but it's clearly oil tankers
are responsible if not that specific one
because it's a classic ballast water
problem and I relate that to point up
the difference in response because those
species of zooplankton out there in
Prince William Sound may in the long run
proved to be infinitely more devastating
than the oil spill itself because there
is some suggestion that those species
may now insert themselves in the food
web from phytoplankton on up that leads
to of the Dungeness
a crab and an important fishery and of
course these are facts that have gone
largely unremarked and unnoticed because
we are dealing with a phenomenon that
unfortunately is out of sight and out of
mind and it is going to be a major task
to try to bring these issues to public
understanding there certainly there you
can go from Prince William Sound down to
the Pacific Northwest where I don't know
30 40 percent of the species and some of
those sounds are now exotic invaders go
to San Francisco Bay well on the way
you'll go past Willapa Bay in Oregon
where got a really fascinating little
very specialized invader problem not
from somebody else's country but from
our own from where the Atlantic coast a
spartina outbreak in Willapa Bay which
is having enormous impacts on their on
the shellfish industry they're reminding
us that these pathways are many and
varied but let's go to San Francisco Bay
this place
surely stands as a warning to what can
happen we're looking at some I don't
know two three hundred species there
fish species of every kind mollusks the
trophic levels of that Bay have been
totally scrambled now the reason that's
important from my perspective is that we
are embarked in California upon a
multi-billion dollar attempt to restore
the ecosystem of the Sacramento the San
Joaquin the Bay Delta and San Francisco
Bay we have spent several years a vast
efforts at trying to reassemble the
ecosystem only to turn
at San Francisco Bay and say what about
the migratory salmon all of the
subspecies the smelt and all the others
if we restore the whole system from the
Sierra Nevada to the Oregon border to
Mexico is it all going to be undone by
this bottleneck in San Francisco Bay
well we don't know other people are
awakening to it it's no different in the
Gulf of Mexico there's a mussel there
that is impacting all sorts of Fisheries
and shoreline ecosystems you know and
then we head to Boston we head up the
Atlantic coast I tell you I didn't know
no Welk was but I'm learning fast -
snail Wow
but this critter is now lurking in
Chesapeake Bay it's coming out of the
old Confederacy straight into the
heartland the American Revolution it's
on its way up Chesapeake Bay it'll
surely quite probably be in your
neighborhood to join all of the other
species that have already altered the
visual coastline of New England and
begun to impact the fisheries here
obviously and I don't need to tell you
this these issues have been around for a
long time the great Columbian Exchange
is only one of many examples and ships
have been toting this stuff around a lot
more slowly and much lesser volume for a
long time and it has clearly for a long
time been a worldwide phenomenon alien
invaders and the decline of endangered
species for those of you who are from
New England I would refer you for an
anecdotal look at this - none other than
Herman Melville you all read Melville in
your spare time well not being a
scientist any longer I thought I'd turn
to Moby Dick for some enlightenment on
this and lo and behold Melville has a
chapter devoted to the whale and this is
of course when the wooden whaling ships
were criss crossing the globe in bloody
pursuit of the Leviathan in a world in
which it was assumed that the ocean
Commons was Infinite and be stable
across a time and space and and Melville
actually pondered he devoted a chapter
to asking whether Leviathan can long
endure so wide a chase and so
remorseless a havoc whether he must not
at last be exterminated from the waters
and interestingly he looked at the great
plains of the American West and he saw
the impending near extinction of the
Buffalo and he then turned back to the
seas and the diminishing whale stocks
and he said no it's impossible on the
high seas because he said if worse comes
to worse whales will escape to the polar
to the icy fortress of the polar regions
and thus become immortal in their
species now obviously that's about an
endangered species but it's a parable
that I think has a lot of power about
the ocean Commons and the concept of
limits and temporal change in the
cultural problem that we face in trying
to persuade the American people and
members of Congress that there can
really be any significant problem with a
Commons
so vast well you know the answer to that
well so what do we do well we haven't
done enough we've done hardly anything
we have one rather limited model that I
think is worth your attention both in
terms of the policies the science the
economics the international cooperation
and that is of course the Great Lakes
because this problem began in the in the
Great Lakes with the construction of two
canals the Wellington canal around
Niagara Falls and the the Erie Canal
which sort of brought us around in
another direction the Great Lakes system
had been effectively isolated in an
evolutionary sense by Niagara Falls and
all of a sudden that barrier was removed
the first signal of trouble was of
course the lamprey which simply
decimated the Great Lakes fisheries and
because of the economics of that fishery
destruction well we took action and we
now have some twenty thirty years of
accumulated science with respect to
attempts to contain the lamprey and
we've of course learned a lesson that
you all know and that is that in most
places in this world and in most
ecosystems the idea of eradication is
simply not within reach we are spending
millions and millions of dollars each
and every year on lamprey control
involving lamb presides electrical
barriers attempts at sterilization all
sorts of very expensive very complex
issues and
well we've managed to do is knock the
lamprey population back to the point
where the fisheries have come up but it
is a continuing struggle and of course
the Great Lakes brings up the
international component this is a joint
Canadian American effort Canada begins
to slack we go up there and raise hell
with them we begin to slack off our
efforts that Canadians are there to urge
us on well that went on for years and
then all of a sudden the zebra mussel
arrives with a vengeance really much
more devastating than the lamprey in the
sense that it's just sort of scrambling
again the trophic levels of the lake
filtering everything in sight through
that system the interesting thing about
the zebra mussel is it actually provoked
a congressional response and the reason
of course is because it was real
clogging up power plants screwing up
boat hulls sort of impacting the fishing
industry and Congress responded there's
an adequate response perhaps as a
beginning we I think have learned a lot
of lessons about how inadequate that
response is the major initiative that
came out of that of course was ballast
water exchange we started off as we
always seem to do in this business by
saying well let's have a voluntary
program and I'm thinking to any of you
know a tanker captain anywhere on the
seven seas who is gonna say well I just
like to voluntarily do this there are a
few sort of pointy-headed scientists and
visionary bureaucrats who would like us
to do it voluntarily
the answer is of course not of course
not this is about raw competitive
economics it is real simple either
everyone doesn't or no one does it
and we have now crossed that divide in
the Great Lakes system from voluntary to
mandatory and of course along the way
we've learned lots of things so you've
got whole pollution problems you've got
the whole issue of ballast sediments
that need to be addressed we've learned
that ballast water exchange is not a
silver bull that there's a long ways to
go on that ultimately we're gonna have
to find some kind of approach that is
more comprehensive whether it's
ultraviolet filtration you name it and
we have not devoted the effort but in
the meantime ballast water exchange is
an important and necessary initiative
which must now be extended to the entire
American coastline now we'll hear a lot
of squawkin a lot of squawkin and we'll
hear the usual things it's not a
complete solution it won't prevent a
hundred percent it will be expensive how
can we retrofit how long can we get
naval architects like Chris into the
action for a new generation ships well
we've heard all of this before we heard
it in the wake of Exxon Valdez all of
the same arguments and we have now quite
successfully moved toward a new set of
oil tanker standards that are being
implemented and the lesson is loud and
clear for ballast water exchange we must
travel the same path now what
specifically should we do well I think
building on the 1990 aquatic invasive
nuisance species Act we need to step
this effort up some of you about a year
ago wrote a letter to the Vice President
highlighting this sin
knowing your talent and clairvoyance we
were moved immediately to a response
which I believe is now going to result
in the issuance of an executive order
from the president
very shortly sometime I would say within
the next several weeks obviously the
details of that remain for the president
but I think I can safely suggest to you
some of the outlines of the directions
that are likely to emerge from that
executive order and there are two of
them that I would highlight well the
first one will be that federal agencies
take steps to use their existing
authorities to prevent any further
damage and to get control of these
introduction problems ballast water
being one but by no means of the only
one well executive orders have an
interesting impact in the United States
government when I came here I assumed
that executive orders were you know just
paper because I'd go over to other
agencies and talk about all these things
and you know the response other agencies
give me is you know who are you to be
over here poaching on our territory and
preaching to us we're doing just fine
State Department always says to me look
you're the Secretary of the Interior you
know you might be a little more modest
about your responsibilities go back to
Buffalo and wolves an executive order
from the president saying get going
we'll have I think a major impact now
the second thing we have to do I believe
will be prompted and moved by an
executive order is put together a truly
comprehensive plan at the go
we've started this with the task force
and the working group that came out of
the 1990 legislation but we got to do a
lot more obviously I've talked about
ballast water and the need for a
nationwide regime which moves toward
mandatory regulations for ballast water
exchange now some of you creative folks
out here have said well what about using
the Clean Water Act and the large
regulatory clout of Environmental
Protection Agency to move straight to in
a straight line to that kind of response
I now see once again I'm I'm over on
somebody else's turf here so I'm gonna
say this with deference to MS browner in
her very able regulators it's an idea
that ought to be discussed it has some
obvious benefits and some obvious
problems in terms of it's one thing to
prescribe regulations is something else
to enforce them and all of a sudden
you're into some very complex issues of
the role of the Coast Guard
international treaties and regulations a
whole variety of issues and it may be
that the Congress will need to deal with
this ballast water issue in a thoughtful
and comprehensive way your question may
be well as the Congress capable of doing
that
now or forever well it's the only system
we've got so the answer is we must now
there's another interesting set of
issues here where I believe the agencies
can with your help and guidance really
make tremendous strides and that is the
use of customs office
Fish and Wildlife inspectors to deal
with the stuff that is coming not by
tanker but is coming through customs the
residue of a very intense global trading
system stuff that comes through in
evades inspection in terms of aquarium
species or the pathogens associated with
raw fish products all kinds of stuff
just by way of illustration somebody did
a study of a just not imper ticularly a
marine issue but it's illustrative of a
ship bringing Japanese timber into
Oregon and found three hundred and
sixty-three species riding along on
those raw logs from Siberia or wherever
and I suspect if we get into this we're
gonna find that we've got a lot of
hitchhikers probably the same magnitude
slipping through in all kinds of
different ways and we simply have to
step up our efforts dan Cimber loss has
a very intriguing idea he says our
attitude toward if you will sort of
customs screening from abroad has always
been black listing species that have
been proven harmful after the effect a
after the fact once the damage is done
then you put it on a blacklist well what
I understand sim Burrell off to be
saying is we should whitelist species
and say nothing
as in until it has been demonstrated as
much as reasonably possible to be if not
benign
at least not malevolent okay we need to
think and act on the research and
development of control mechanisms
whether they are a chemical fire or bio
controls whatever it may be and the
problem with our research effort now is
that like so much of government is it
it's fragmented and it tends to be
directed at specific issues we need a
crash project on Melaleuca trees in the
Florida Everglades we go to agriculture
and say search the world for the
biocontrol
we get a leafy spurge problem out west
and all of a sudden we're scouring the
universe looking for bio controls we
tend to deal with it in a very
fragmented kind of fashion and somehow
we got to look across our scientific
establishment and that's in the
Department of Agriculture NOAA the
Department of Interior universities
grant and aid programs and SFC grant
programs and see if we can't find an
organizing principle no yeah the genius
of scientific research in this country
and indeed in many other countries is
that nobody's in charge of setting the
agenda except individual centers
institutions and scientists your freedom
is the source of the creative genius of
our system but it also leads to anarchy
and there must be some way of imposing
just the slightest amount of non
invasive non-demanding sort of
couldn't we all consider that the
following things made systemic attention
and I believe that the President's
budget a request for the year 2000 is
going to head in that direction with
respect to the federal agencies but
lastly just a word about the
international issues you're aware that
this is not a one-way problem anybody
who has seen the damage that has been
done to the Black Sea Fisheries by our
export of is a dhobi species also comb
jelly okay the decimation of those
Fisheries is ample evidence that this is
a modern Colombian exchange that goes in
all directions and that in fact to have
effective controls prevention controls
you ought to be working at both ends of
the transportation a pathway where it
starts and where it ends yeah that's
going to be a difficult difficult
endeavor but we must get started
there are a number of international
biological treaties and we have a World
Trade Organization which I will
undoubtedly play a regulatory role
my own belief is that the biodiversity
treaty is the correct way to handle this
though we need to acknowledge it head-on
as a pervasive biological issue and walk
straight back to that treaty in section
8 and see if we can begin the process of
acknowledging and negotiating the
outlines of a protocol that will deal
that is know some of you out there
skeptical may ask well that's absolutely
fascinating
considering that the United States has
never even ratified the biological
diversity treaty interesting problem
the treaties enforce their conventions
regular conventions of the parties and
where are we well just as a mild
suggestion not meant to be disrespectful
but perhaps we could prevail upon the
United States Senate currently absent
from all of these issues behind closed
doors dealing with those matters
to take on these issues and to get with
the urgent necessity of ratifying that
treaty and starting a vigorous and
fruitful debate about how we find the
tools to deal with these problems in a
global context well I didn't mean to go
on so long dusty I'll get started and I
seldom have a captive audience for these
kinds of things and I very much
appreciate the invitation and in all
seriousness I would end where I started
and that is that your efforts together
to raise the profile and deepen our
understanding of these issues can and
hopefully will be the beginning of a
brand new chapter in our recognition and
attention to this problem thank you
[Applause]
do we have some questions yep
secretary Babbitt Armand cures from the
University of California at Santa
Barbara the news that the
administration's executive order to
prevent the entry of exotic marine
species is an extremely extremely good
news as this will certainly greatly
reduce the future problems but what
about the established pests the
introduced the marine pests that are
already here and are doing damage or
have the potential to do considerable
damage does the administration plan the
development of a coherent policy perhaps
using tools such as subsidized fisheries
biological control genetic manipulation
in an integrated pest management
approach to these problems the answer
the question is yes now a few thoughts
obviously there's an enormous amount of
interest in biological controls and we
have a melancholy history that you all
know about with well-intentioned
attempts to find the Mongoose and bring
it into Hawaii to take care of whatever
it was the rats are yes and rabbits in
Australia for whatever purpose and what
we have learned over the last couple
hundred years is that this is a very
difficult issue and it requires a lot of
discipline and caution we are currently
as you well know experimenting on land
in the terrestrial systems what there's
some pretty encouraging preliminary
results for the Department of
Agriculture is doing really systematic
screening and we have turned some
critters loose on the mallalieu can
Florida we've got some now moving on the
purple loosestrife front somewhat leafy
spurge out west but we've also been
experimenting
in the terrestrial systems with a
variety of other issues a fire it's
interesting fire like bio controls can
make matters worse we've had a sort of
unhappy experience with cheatgrass which
you know that accelerates the natural
fire cycle it burns every year and it
destroys everything else and it's an
annual which co-evolved with domestic
livestock in Europe and Asia and those
ecosystems historically had fire but
they didn't have cheatgrass and now when
they have fire and cheatgrass
we've got kind of an insoluble a problem
there well I think the reason I'm going
terrestrial is it's a implicit
acknowledgment that we're not yet really
onto these issues in coastal waters but
the answer is absolutely yes we're not
gonna get rid of most of these things
we're gonna have to find strategies of
containment that minimize the damage and
focus our research do the best we can
admit we don't know everything take an
occasional risk and hope hope for the
best
yeah
right here if you just holler the
question if I like it I'll repeat it if
not yeah good morning mr. secretary I'm
a project manager with the regional
Citizens Advisory Council in Valdez so
your opening comments with a particular
interest one of the big gaps in the
national base of Species Act was the
elimination or the setting aside of
coastwise trade as not participating in
the and the voluntary ballast water
exchange program and as you probably
know in Valdez we get a lot of we get a
lot of ballast from the u.s. from ports
that are themselves heavily invaded and
that is obviously of concern to us
because we want to protect the bio
integrity of Prince William Sound our so
the question I guess is simply a
political one can we count on you for
the support of changing that requirement
of when the when the national invasive
species act is up for renewal well I
think the logic of dealing with this
internationally applies equally to two
national transfers I mean the spartina
problem in Willapa Bay is from the
Atlantic to the Pacific now I don't know
whether that's what time I got there on
a boat or whether it just sort of was in
somebody's pocket or whether somebody
did it deliberately but that to me
stands for the proposition that we must
include this kind of analysis and
controls but I just read yesterday the
Atlantic salmon is now apparently loose
in Puget Sound as a result of some
aquaculture issues in in British
Columbia and there is just absolutely no
question that we have to see it in that
and have the authority to do it so the
answer is yes way in the back
you would do and we appreciate that but
I wonder if there's if you could give us
some hints on how we could do a better
job how can you do a better job well
look you're the ones with the
credibility on this problem I got to
tell you there a lot of places well
maybe a surprise to you but there are a
considerable number of places in this
country where if I say something the
tendency will want to a public response
will they disbelief and a desire to do
exactly the opposite in light of my
credibility in the modern political
system you've got the credibility and I
think that imposes upon you particularly
in a complex modern society the
imperative of advocacy now you know I
don't think you need to cross the line
into the political arena what I mean by
advocacy is finding appropriate and
imaginative ways to highlight these
issues and the economic consequences one
thing that lies buried out there is the
economic consequences of the problems
that we already have we are spending
billions of dollars on containment
issues and with a corresponding amount
of lost revenues I think there's a
Cornell study out I would encourage you
all to look at that Cornell a paper and
ask how can I translate this in my
community because ultimately the
willingness of congressmen Congress men
and women to act is not a function of my
speeches it's a function of what they're
hearing from their constituents and you
are their constituent
right here I'm Andy Cohen from the San
Francisco estuary Institute you you
mentioned during your talks the the
issue of the whitelist versus the
blacklist approach to regulating
intentional introductions in 1973 the US
Fish and Wildlife Service in fact
recommended a change to a whitelist
approach it was in 1973 a political and
untenable idea but there's a lot more
concern about the issue this year and
there's as you said in an impending
presidential executive order can we
expect that the Department of the
Interior will show the boldness that the
Fish and Wildlife Service did back in
1973 and recommend a change to a
whitelist approach that question
translated is beneath all the rhetoric
are you
too wimpy to do what was promised
25 years ago well I believe that some
variant of that is has to be done in
some form and that this interagency task
force he will be given an 18-month
mandate to prepare a comprehensive plan
legislation regulation budget forgotten
past promises I'll still be there and I
haven't forgotten your question okay let
me wait take a couple more this must be
yeah clear clear over here yeah yeah
okay this is the last one it's 11
o'clock and I think I've stayed out of
trouble so far so let's see what happens
it's usually the last one that bites you
and provides the headline which provokes
a call from the president saying Bruce
what is it you were advocating up there
with that lead-in mr. secretary I'm
gonna have to change my question
actually I'm Rachel Jacobs from the
Naval Surface Warfare Center out in
Carderock Wow with the problem with
ballast water and in terms of what
research we need to do we've been told
that we need to look into the problem
and yet we've been given no guidelines
and what exactly we need to do to
compensate for ballast on Navy ships
which is as much of a problem on
commercial ships as well and basically I
was wondering when the federal
government your department and others
would start giving us guidelines that we
can actually go and create the
technology to handle there's always been
a question whether or not the policy
pushes the technology or whether the
technology pushes the policy and I'm
wondering when Congress is going to say
what are the standards that we need to
uphold well I would respectfully submit
now in my seventh year of dealing with
the messy business of making policy in
Washington that you would be
well-advised to say to the Admirals and
whoever you work with we can't possibly
rely on having these folks up their hand
some policy down from on high we've got
to drive the policy we but what is a
naval attack and warfare anestis NSWC
basically Naval Surface Warfare Center
we're right to the right to the west of
you what you gotta have
what you got to do is design a battle
plan well then let me ask you another
problem with the same question artillery
and win we know we know that the
scientific community is working on the
problem of invasive species of ballast
water and other issues all pertaining to
the same however there always seems to
be a bit of a gap between what the
scientific community does and then what
we can convince Congress what they need
to do and the extent of the problem is
there any way to expedite the transfer
of knowledge back and forth well I hope
you will join our little task force that
is going to be forthcoming as a result
of the president's order and we can get
this thing stirred up know now seriously
and then I'll quit there's always a gap
between the emerging science consensus
around a problem and the natural
reluctance of society to make large
changes in the way we go about our
economic life if you want a really large
example of that look at climate change
how frustrated do you think those
scientists are we have an absolutely
rock-solid consensus on the reality of
climate change the the factors which are
driving that are simple enough to be
understood by a high school student and
yet the policymakers step back that's a
particularly egregious example but it's
it's part of the process and what it
leads me to is saying you know you've
really got two alternatives one is to
send the elected representatives to
school you know bring them to MIT
the other one is to say to the
scientists you've got to sort of step up
across the gap into non-political
advocacy advocacy which is grounded upon
your special expertise and the gifts
which this society has allowed you to
develop and repay us by stepping into
the very risky public arena cautiously
but very firmly using your scientific
weapons to accelerate the debate thank
you very much
[Applause]